ウゼェ！！
オーマジ時間ねぇんだよぉモォーおー
おけ
行ってきます！
ありがとう東京の家…
二か月間
お世話になりましたぁ！
タクシー運転手：沖縄ですか？
はじめ：はい
運：あ、じゃぁこの手前の方でいいですか
は：はい。ありがとうございまーす
は：ありがとうございました。
運：ありがとうございます。
オッス！俺ハトシ！
ポケモン東京で二か月ほどやったんですけども正直もうほぼ
コンプリートです（ニヤリ
俺が捕まえていないポケモンと言えばあと二匹
…と
沖縄にしか出ない
そして今日ハトシは
今日こそハトシはぁ
よ　う　や　く　ハ　ト　シ　は
静岡に帰ります
んまじです
そのまま静岡帰ろうと思ったんですけども
バ☆カ☆ヤ☆ロ
大切な忘れ物をしてしまった
サニーゴポケモンgoでサニーゴって実は
日本だと沖縄とか鹿児島のあの奄美とかあのけっこう赤道近くの地域にしか出ないらしくてぇ
俺は何としても
ホントにもう何としてでも僕はサニーゴを捕まえたい
サニーゴだけを捕まえたいんですよ
ね？わかる？
サニーゴをどうしても捕まえたいんで
東京頑張った僕に御褒美というわけでもないですけど
サニーゴだけは捕まえて静岡に帰りたいと思ってるんで
今日はただいま朝の８時前
何としてでも
何としてでも今日は
あ、やべ＄％＆バス超いや、恥ずかしいやばい、ちょっと、めっちゃバスから見られてる…逃げなきゃ
恥ずかしいよぉ
カメラに向かってしゃべってるの変だよぉ…///
まぁ簡単に言うと
日帰りで
俺を待つ家、静岡に帰ろうと思います
みんなに内緒でこっそり一人で沖縄の便をとって
行きの便帰りの便もとってあって完璧に静岡に帰れる状態になってるんで
沖縄にほんの少ししかいられないっす。たぶん
３時間ぐらいしかたぶん滞在できないんですけど
僕初めて国内線乗るんですよ
沖縄でサニーゴを捕まえるだけの飛行機なんで
はたしてサニーゴを捕まえるのにどれくらいの時間がかかるのか今回検証していこうと思います
いやービビるぜ
これで捕まんなかったら俺マジ終わりだぜ？
MILE(参る)
やべ、迷子なう
スマホケースもあきらめかけてて
沖縄行く時ぐらい外そうと思ったんですけど
俺はそれでもつけていきます
あいで、おもいっ
ｶﾞﾀﾝ　重いよ
ガシャン！　　ｱｱｯ　　ｲｲｲｲｲｲｯ!!
俺のフレンドだぜー
イェーーーーーーーーーーーーイ
平日なのに全然…
あぁ修学旅行か
平日だけど修学旅行だから人がいましたね
それも同じ飛行機だよ!?だいじょうぶかな？
じゃみんな楽しんでね
男生徒：はい！さようなら！
女子生徒：ｳｪｪｪｪｪｪｪｪ!?!?!?!?!?!
女子：ｲﾔｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧ!!!!!　　ｷｨｴｱｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧl!!!!!!
やばいやばい。やばい
騒ぎになってもうたわ
赤ちゃん：ｴｪｪｪｪｪｪﾍﾍwwww　ｳｴｪｪｪｪｪｪﾝﾍﾍwww
は：・・・　赤ちゃん：ｳｳｪｪｪｪｪｪlﾝﾍﾍwww　ｴｴｴｴｴﾝﾍﾍwww
かばん見逃す
あ、俺のじゃん！
はい、というわけで沖縄着きました
盛大にバレてしまったんですけど
まぁ許容範囲でしょう
ここでハイサイ探偵団が
迎えに来てくれるはずなんですけど
よっしゃー
ひっちゃそ～
ひっちゃん：本当に一週間使ってる
は:ハイサイ探偵団のひっちゃんです
ひ:どうも～
ひ:あ、あの車で
は：あ、あの車で
は：あ、助六さんじゃないっすか
助六さん？：助六さん誰スかそれ？！
は：助六さんじゃないすか
は：助六さん
助六？：絶対俺のことしらない
は：イヤ知ってますよ
は：助六さんですよね
助六？：めっちゃ間違えてるじゃないっすか
は：竹内？
ひ：武
は：武ですよね
武：はい武です。
は：もちろんです
た：助六ｓ、
は：えー14:30
ひ：あと1時間ぐらいしかない
た：あと１時間
は：てか暑いっすねー
ひ：暑いっすよー
は：暑い！
は：ピーーーー
た：どうしたんすか
は：なんでもない
は：いいなー沖縄
は：もっと居たかったなー
は：僕今日まで東京にいて
は：今日静岡帰ろうと思ってたんですよ
ひ：えー
は：ただやりのこしたことは
は：あると。
ひ：沖縄はまだ夏ですからねえ
は：まだ夏ですよね
は：うわー生き損ですわ
ひ：どうすか出そうすか
は：今のところないです
た：あモノレール
は：モノレール
は：ギリアウト
ひ：15人しか乗んねぇスあれ多分あれ
は：15人？！
は：とりあえずあれですよね、何とか何とか公園
は：西崎運動公園
は：行ければ
は：ぼくが
は：一番好きなポケモンなんだと思います？
は：数いるポケモンの中で
た：あのーなんですかね
た：カレーライス
た：あーなるほどなるほど
は：一番好きなのサニーゴなんですよ
た：え
ひ：え
た：ほんとすか
は：ただサンゴの形なんですけど
は：すごい笑顔なんですよ
た：あ笑顔
は：可愛くないすか
た：笑顔が好きなんですね
は：笑顔がいいポケモンなんですよ
た：あ、なるほど
た：だから動画でこうリスナーさんを笑顔にするっていう気持ちでやってるってことですね
た：あ、そういうことではない(笑)
ひ：なかなか出てこねっすね
は：なかなか出てこない
た：これちょっとあれだな
た：ちょっとプレッシャー感じ、
は：ちょっとやばいですね
た：捕れるって言ったからにはちょっと責任がありますから、私にも
は：確かに
は：いないかな～
た：なかなか見つからんすね
は：あっはっはっはっはっはっはっはっはっ
ひ：お、映った
た：お、あ、いた
は：まっているいる
ひ：いるってストップ　スットプ　ストップ
は：はー！！やばいやばい
は：待ってすごい可愛い
は：これどうにかして捕まえないと
は：これが俗にいうサニーゴですわ
ひ：モンスターボールも変えていく
は：はいっ
た：さあっ
は：さあっ
た：さあ、どうだっ
は：やったーーー！！！！
エンディング♪
は：サニーゴ♡
ひ：サニーゴ
は：はぁたまんねえぜ
は：よっしゃオッケー行きましょう
は：サニーゴ捕まえましたー！
は：じゃあ、、帰ります
ありがとうございました
た：気を行けて
は：ありがとうございます
は：でわっ
は：二か月ぶりの静岡です
たくみふくしゃちょー：凄い音楽してるよ
たくみ：えっ！
たくみ：沖縄行ったの？
たくみ：はじめー？
たくみ：サニーゴ？